okay thanks thanks everyone eh my name
is Gonzalo rodríguez I'm the CEO and
co-founder at a boom ba a we are a
developer of educational apps for kids
under the age of 5 and today I wanted to
mention a couple of experiments and
things learnings that we have in the
last pass in the last three years while
localizing our apps and going global and
I think it's important given all all
that has been said today especially
about the emerging markets that are
going to be very important in the next
two years a so hopefully you find
interesting there is a lot of data so
hope it is understandable so I already
mentioned we do early educational apps
for kids under the age of five we focus
in some certain categories like running
the alphabet learning the numbers and we
cover some certain cognitive skills from
the kids that are still learning
vocabulary like animal sounds first
words until kids that reached the age of
five and are ready to start a school
right so we definitely promote learning
through play our apps are a combination
of a of learning methods that combine a
lot of gaming and interaction especially
because our audience is so so small they
need to learn all the time while playing
and at last we study the company always
taking into account or with a vision of
being global we started from day zero
with a problem that I'm going to tell
you in the next slide next slide sorry I
have the agenda and it's it has three
part of the presentation first one is
why do we decide to go global and all
the challenges we had in the meantime a
good challenges I really fun challenges
I really promote and we'll try to sort
of transmit that these fun challenges
are really good and at last some
experiments and results that we we can
share with you and are very actionable
points and data that we are going to
share very
intimate of our kitchen and I hope you
find useful
so first wait why would you say to go
global okay why we decided to go global
as many of the developers here probably
not the ones that are like cartoon a
door but morally the one that studied us
enterpreneurs we found that there was a
problem especially when when kids from
our nephews or sons we're trying to use
apps and they were basically all in
English so we had this big problem that
we were trying all the time to translate
what the voice-over said and and we
imagined in Portuguese happen the same a
couple of years ago there were many
alternatives in this specific field for
the early childhood a category so we we
were asked all the time and especially
in this past three years why why would
you go global
eh why wouldn't you focus for example in
the Spanish market that we we're from
Argentina so we we kind of know the
language and we can make a difference on
that or why wouldn't you focus in the US
market that is more mature and you have
better chances of making more revenue so
a we we thought at that moment that this
particular issue was going to be a
global like many many people from all
over the world we're going to use the
apps in English only and we're going to
have this problem what while trying to
to help their kids learn useful stuff
like the alphabet on the other hand we
we had we found this opportunity three
years ago that when we started the
company we we found amazing translators
and crowdsourcing services that probably
ten years ago if we had this this vision
would have been much more difficult but
at that specific moment we found it was
quite easy to get talented voiceovers in
several languages I'm going to tell you
we were localizing the apps in 15
languages and also it was very
unexpected and also very easy to
implement so I think once you start
seeing our metrics in in downloads and
how after localizing is started to grow
probably more more than one of you will
starting
in localizing in languages like Asia or
Eastern Europe and our countries so this
this graph I I like it a lot because
when we launched it our first up it was
an animal sounds are very simple but we
launched it already in three languages
it was in Portuguese in English and in
Spanish and as you can see broadly
brazil was our first country in dowse
for a period of 12 months we have over
over 35% of the traffic coming from
brazil then we have around 40% traffic
coming from a spanish-speaking countries
then us about 9% so we launched the app
and immediately we had like 84 percent
of the traffic using their app in their
native language which was great like if
they feedback we got and the reviews
were amazing because people were
actually surprised that we took care of
different languages in one single app
and then we have countries like
languages like Indonesia a German and
India that were like in the long time
but we were still like obsessed with
with this last statistics we were assess
that 60% 16% of the traffic were using
the app in a foreign language and we we
said okay this is happening like the
same happened to us is happening in
countries like France in countries like
Italy so they are using an app and
translating the the app to your kid so
what we did right after we took like
localization that was something that has
been said a lot today like super serious
we decided to create a global team I'm
going to tell you how I'm going to share
our method to do it we have to decide at
what point which languages were going to
be to be included because there are too
many languages and we have to make at
least a one cut and we this the decision
for us was pretty easy we left some cut
some languages or countries that
potentially might be very good for
revenue but short in reach and we
decided to go for a megabit in the
emerging countries in the merging
markets so we
we cover languages like Indonesia Arabic
in the Malaysia Philippines all with
voiceovers in those countries voiceovers
and well that that is like the hardest
part like to get quality voice overs but
everything is localized even the lowest
localizing Indian we were crazy trying
to understand if we made the correct a
understanding but in turnout rate and
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
it and then we we knew that we were
going to fail in on so many levels
especially because we we were facing on
other cultures and well people have
different visions like for example in
some countries that something that you
think that is good culture for you might
be completely a the opposite in our
culture so we had to we study to check
the reviews all day and study to respond
and understand which were our weaknesses
in win our apps we got a lot but we we
set it to after conversation we started
to improve that a lot so this is our
graphic now two years later of the same
that I've shown before after localizing
so basically you can see here all the
only blue countries were the original
languages that we array cover Brazil is
still in the position number two is
still like in the top three but then we
have a lot of new countries that are in
the top position and see he's happy like
Indonesia it has like 10x growth in
every year for us it is massive they are
downloading the apps like crazy and
there are some other countries that are
in we're we say that we are experiment
in this emerging market revolution but
only the beginning India France Turkey
Italy France a Turk a France and Italy
are always ready not emerging but those
are the countries that are now in our
top 10 in downloads and for us it's
amazing because it drives different
questions like for example I don't want
to go ahead to a presentation but you
have to think of different business
model for all this variety of countries
it's not like a the inner purchases that
cost six dollars in the u.s. is the same
in Indonesia because they have
differentiation power
have different payment mentality so it
drives a lot of good questions so what
we did was we we did something that we
call inside the company we did like a
big audition like an America die either
we felt like Simon Cowell analyzing all
kind of voiceovers from all over the
world and we interview by then interview
more than 300 voiceovers because we
needed to cover 15 languages I a CEO
you're very copy because actually it was
like a complete process that took about
two or three months we we knew that we
had to do great a great team that would
join us for the rest of the app because
it's like you get a voice over that the
kids like and then you cannot change
because that people doesn't work anymore
as a voice over you have to find quality
people and then we have the other
challenge which smoke was smaller but
still we had to find quality translators
and a tours because especially when you
work in the kids industry you need to be
very delicate about everything that you
say and I well we found this this good
team that now is showing all our games
so final result after 400 people that we
interview in this big audition we have
now a staff that works with us 25
voiceover talents we we cover 15
languages sorry so we have 10 substitute
substitutes for any any kind of thing
and then we have 30 translators with
editors that help us a review and check
descriptions we have some very oh we
have all the time things that we get
from the a tours team review for example
last time week ago we got one one word
in Russian that says like child care and
there was our little symbol be amazing
that says poison so we get all the time
this kind of situations but it's
something you can solve it quite easy so
process took about two months like I was
saying but the good thing about this is
that now localizing an app for us into
15 languages since we have all the text
in the first language it takes only 20
days so it is very easy
once you start thinking in the products
that will be global it's pretty easy to
in the technological side it is much
easier if you start thinking in being
global from scratch then trying then to
a well start making some fixes so this
is this another funny thing because when
we started we obviously start revising
everything with our ears that are
Spanish we understand a little bit us or
to his English of course and then we
have a little of Italian that we
understand too so we we knew that one of
the challenges was to reach the same
quality in all languages for example we
we said we need to reach the same
quality in Malay that is another crazy
language group for us we don't
understand anything that in Spanish
that was our let's say our KPI so we
have this a we have to do a lot of
understanding and reading reviews and
this is a very good example of how a
simple thing in the content can change a
lot the reviews like in the Arabic
language we we weren't that aware but
the ping is a very prohibited animal
like in the culture and especially for
kids is like if you show the pig you're
messing up like don't do it so we gotta
look good a lot of reviews that that
says the app is quite good but you
cannot show this to my children we were
off we don't want to start doing this
game that we have to adapt every every
part of the game to every language but
the reviews kept coming kept coming
hundred and the rating came really down
until three point nine so after removing
the pig now Arab the Arabic language is
the first in our rating and that there
is something I think it's a good example
of how by understanding and reading
reviews you can do a massive improvement
in your ratings so and this is this is
how it lies in our animal sound shop
which is the one that has more downloads
has around four million by that by now
this is the top languages in writing so
obviously Spanish we speak Spanish and
we we couldn't believe that in
Arabic or in Russian we were doing
better but I think this this is a very
good point to to understand and for you
to know that in those in those languages
there are many options available for for
kids so the users really appreciate when
you a create quality content for them so
it is impossible I think to get a better
a quality that your native language but
it seems to be very even but there is a
plus because you are doing in the
language that is not very common and
well there is a a very funny or example
there is Indonesia Indonesia as I was
saying is the first country in Dallas
with this app but we have the lowest
rating is 3 point 98 and after reading
reviews we understood what was happening
they used to say the Koba do Lu the Goa
Doo Lu became like a word all the time
in our head and the Cthulhu means I'm
going to try the app first and then I'm
going to review cabins that they they
forget to update the review so these are
very interesting example also because
sometimes you think that you have
something wrong in your app and it's
something cultural and we we ask for
reviews to the users on a certain time
like in the third or fourth session so
it might be like a good idea to start
thinking for example Indonesia don't ask
right away because the users have this
commitment to to put a review and then
evaluate the app so these are the kind
of things that we are learning by using
the reviews and well resolved is the
some percentage of the people that says
that the app is the in-app purchases are
expensive but that is a main issue the
de Guadalupe oh well at last this is
what we are more focused now because we
have the app available in where we have
downloads from 140 countries in 15
languages so we obviously know that it
is it is simpler to have the same price
for example in Germany it than Indonesia
or it just doesn't work like the
percentage of paying users it's
ridiculous
if you have the same pricing in all so
when we we knew that the new feature of
the pricing tiers and and and the
templates came came out with
testing a lot and I have three things
that I would like to to share like the
experiments that might be some
highlights so after what we did I will
explain very simple we did a division of
three tiers
we created a tier that was the top 15
countries in the world that spent more
in gaming and we put it them in the
first column then the second like
countries like Brazil Argentina that
spend more less than let's say Japan and
we put in the second row and then they
have we have the other countries that is
spin less that are more oriented to ads
and we put in the third column so
basically the first column had a hundred
percent of the price the second 70% of
the price and the other 50% of the price
that was experiment we weren't trying to
to understand if that made a difference
so for example in countries like Russia
when we did this 30 percent discount we
saw a 70% increase in sales and this
this is like if you start doing this on
every country and start focusing you
will see that there are difference but
it is very impressive the growth we
having in Russia Russia is one of our
top 15 countries in downloads then we
put a reduced price in Latin America and
we saw that it didn't make any
difference for us at least like people
it is just a percentage that my pay or
not but if in that specific case when we
reduce the price we had the same amount
of people but just less revenue but it's
interesting to see and try because maybe
maybe the price is still not very
attractive to users that are willing to
to spend $1 $2 and then at last this is
just very simple Ana and we were like
very angry we didn't do it before we saw
a significant increase by just running
up the Europe price because the Google
Play console like if you do the auto
conversion it rounds for example from
$0.99 it was 0 89 by I think now it is
auto converted but when we understood
that we said ok we have to run up every
price because probably was confusing
people who say why is it zero
89 and we sell like in countries like
Italy he had like 45 50 percent of
increase in sales so that is something
very easy to do one if you have ABS
distributor I suggest you do it so I
have been showing some results but I
wanted to show you like more the big
picture of how once we started
localizing how it turn out so we took
here to countries Italy and France as
examples let's say that Italian friends
were having without the localized
version so we when we having we're
having the three languages let's say 100
downloads every day so after localizing
just the first month we had three times
that that amount after six months we had
four times after a year we had five
times so I think it good it shows quite
good and the the huge potential of
localizing because if you do it on on a
regular basis and with with 15 languages
like we did we had like three times the
downloads in general and there are some
countries like Indonesia that the the
growth was 10 times so i really suggest
you do it and well before localizing
asia and europe was only 18 percent of
the traffic and after organizing is 51
and the other the other localized
languages are still growing not not like
the the ones that we localized now but
this gave a huge percentage of new users
and especially in revenue so these are
the I think the last two charts a this
is how it looked like our revenue top
grossing countries in Google Play before
organizing so basically you had us
Raziel Mexico Argentina and Chile after
organizing we have the big increase or
or interruption of countries like Italy
Germany and France that are now in our
top five countries in revenue
and this is something since all or the
majority of the developers are obviously
focusing in English cities the most
important language is important to point
that now for us English is is still huge
like 44% of the revenue but the other is
much bigger and all combined I strongly
believe that the emerging markets will
start getting Airy every time much more
more in in revenue and in downloads so
expect to see this emerging market
revolution happen so the last chart is
like our top four tips of what we think
users find valuable in this specific
thing in localizing so number one is
having native voiceovers that can give
clear instruction to children especially
if you are producing apps for kids under
the age of five or under the age of
seven is hugely important for parents
you have someone that is guiding the
experience then we usually only every
day we enter to a console and answer
reviews in their native language and
that's we sometimes we get a two or
three stars
but after replying in their native
language they the outcome is usually a
day at least put four stars and we get a
lot of updated reviews like we get at
the email and we check and it happens a
lot
so we also localized everything the
soleus in the title we even try
localizing the icons and put a flag in
the last play time here in Brazil we
said that that was working great a
turnout that once we did the icon
experiment that didn't work as we
expected but still we try to localize
everything even the app title
screenshots everything and at last this
is something that we learn by knocking
our head a few times against the wall if
you start localizing everything it's
very important that you start thinking
in a not including a lot of text because
you are marke much more willing to do
errors so the more images and more
voiceovers you can include that's the
better so thank you